Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Today!
Today is the 60th episode!
Thank you for joining us!
BAU BAU!
I can't believe it.
It feels like it was just the 50th episode the other day.
I don't know.
It feels like we started everything every day.
Wow!
Ruffians, for those of you who are joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Christmas is just around the corner.
Is there anything you're looking forward to?
Are you trying to embarrass me?
I don't know.
Well... I think there's been another Pero Sighting!
How are you not gonna answer my question?
It's embarrassing!
Pero Sighting.
Yikes.
Ruffians.
Yikes?
That's what you have to say.
Ruffians.
You have some interesting tastes, you know.
Pero, what are you doing?
You know, you were just helping the kids, and now... Huh?
You were hearing what kind of gifts they wanted the other day.
And now... This.
Bikini modeling!
Sweater modeling!
Why is he making that face too?
It's sort of like...
He doesn't have the confidence in himself for, like, maybe... He pities the Ruffians!
Boldy displaying this calendar!
Those rosy cheeks.
I think he knows what he's up to.
But, you know, also, Moco-chan, look at his little wings, you know?
They're doing their best!
Yeah!
I see it!
It's a little bit tight, yeah?
Yeah, it looks a little rough on them, but...
You know, yeah, maybe we shouldn't be too hard on Pero.
Right?
He's trying something new.
You know, it's not easy being a bikini model when you're Pero, right?
When you're Pero.
Yeah.
Well, thank you for sharing his debut link with us.
Thank you, Ruffians.
I don't know if we need that.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, let's just forget about that.
Pero Sighting, I think of something much happier because guess what, Ruffians?
Well, you might know, but we released both of our solo versions of Cute na Kanojo!
BAU BAU BAU!
Did you listen?
What did you think?
You know, Ruffians, we swear we weren't able to be there in the premiere with you, but we were there in spirit!
Thank you for listening!
BAU BAU!
We hope that you enjoyed them a lot and that you listen to them over and over and over, okay?
You know, it's interesting because you can see, you know, how Fuwawa sings something versus how I sing something.
It wasn't really possible to do that before.
So now, Ruffians, you shouldn't have any problems telling our voices apart, right?
BAU BAU!
That was awesome!
Thank you!
A little bit nervous, too.
And also, Ruffians, if you're nearby, we hope that you'll come and see us!
Yeah!
You know, right?
If you're nearby.
If you're nearby, okay.
Yeah, it might be tricky.
You know, this time of year, I think everybody's going everywhere, right?
Yeah, but we'll be having a big panel there!
And there'll be like a Q&A and a mini welcome party!
So we hope that you'll be ready with
BAU BAU!
Only get at the event, so don't forget to get your paws on them too, okay?
Moco-chan, are you okay?
Suddenly a dragon!
That's how excited you are, huh?
That excited, huh?
BAU BAU!
We hope to see you at Comiket!
I'm so excited, but...
I'm a little nervous too, oh my gosh.
It'll be okay though, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians.
I'm not too sure about in Malaysia about the... the situation regarding this.
But!
Well...
Pororo onee-chan just had a brand new episode of Legend of Pororo Cup.
And she talked all about the situation of hololive members and how they dip their nuggets.
Very gripping, very important information.
The most important of information about Ruffians.
Do you slice?
How much sauce?
You know, it was that sort of important information.
Important, yeah.
And you know, FUWAMOCO, we were featured too!
Yeah!
Just, uh, maybe for the Ruffians who can't read Japanese.
Is this an English subtitle?
No.
No?
Okay.
Safe.
Ruffians, how do you feel that FUWAMOCO feels towards sauce on nuggets?
Oh.
You use enough?
What is enough?
Mococo probably drenches it.
Can't get enough sauce?
No!
Well, FUWAMOCO, we're no sauce!
No sauce!
You know, we like to taste the flavor of the animal, of the meat.
You know, if we wanted to taste sauce, then we'd just have sauce, huh?
You know, this is a time for the meat to shine, not the sauce.
Not the sauce, you know.
Ruffians, why are you making that face?
It's not like we really have nuggets very often, but when we do, there is never any sauce involved.
Do you understand, Ruffians?
Yeah, don't you feel like it's kind of rude to use sauce?
Right.
You know, think of what the nugget wants the most.
Right!
What the nugget wants!
It wants to have its time to be enjoyed.
Uh-huh.
Think about the nuggets feeling okay.
Yeah, and then the sauce just comes along, it's gonna steal its spotlight.
You know.
We can't have that.
Yeah, so we do what's kindest, and we eat it with no sauce.
Honey mustard?
No way!
Disgusting.
No, this is the best way.
The kindest way.
BAU BAU!
Why yuck?
How?
Do you not like nuggets?
Why are you eating nuggets if you say yuck?
How can you be so mean to the nuggets?
Right.
Wow, Ruffians.
You're kind of rude, huh?
They just woke up and they decided to say, I'm gonna be rude!
Yeah!
Rude to the nuggets.
Oh my goodness.
Well, BAU BAU.
Well, Ruffians, just because of that, we have something new for you.
We have a new challenge.
This might be, you know, Ruffians, if you like to have sauce on your nuggets, maybe the new challenge is no sauce.
But!
Well, to explain, you know, at the beginning of the week, Moco-chan challenges herself to overcome her dislike of natto, right?
Yeah, recently, Moco-chan, thanks to the sesame oil, right?
Things have started to somehow... Start!
Go better, right?
It's starting.
Starting, yeah.
Yeah, we're all super surprised, right?
Yeah!
Natsu is not done.
Yeah, it was kinda looking like we're starting to go back with Moco-chan.
A bit.
That there's starting to be some trauma forming.
Yeah, but, you know, since you started to get the hang of it, Ruffian?
Next Monday, we'll be changing things up!
Changing it!
We want you to join us in the challenge though, okay?
This time, we'll be challenging ourselves, both of us, to... Eggnog!
Ruffians!
You better get ready too, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Smells really bad.
But we're gonna do our best!
So please join us, Ruffians!
You know, whether you like it or not.
It might be the holidays, you know, but really, that doesn't mean we can stop challenging ourselves to new things, okay?
Just eggnog!
Just straight eggnog.
No adding milk, no adding water.
Just eggnog.
Not eggnog annatto.
No.
Homie, that sounds dangerous.
From the store.
Yeah.
Safety.
We're importing our specialty, okay?
Because it's hard to get in the Northwest Passage.
So, we hope that you'll join us, okay?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, it seems like we got an important news scoop!
Thank you for the impeccable journalism!
Ruffians, it seems like there is a big update to FUWAMOCO!
It's a very special event going on right now.
And me, Mococo!
I'm a part of it!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
This time the cave screen is icy and slippery, so only the hololive members who had the best deciding are a part of it.
That means I'm a part of it.
You know, it's actually a super fun update, so if you haven't played it yet, you really should.
Yeah.
You know, you can even play it on mobile too!
You know, I actually really like it so much.
I hope they'll leave it in the game forever.
It's pretty fun.
Yeah.
You know, it's really unique and refreshing.
It kind of changes things up a lot.
So, please try it out, okay?
You need to try it out, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Can you believe it, Moco-chan?
It's already a very fluffy and fuzzy part of the day.
We have our... Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
The Doggie of the Day today is... Tiny!
Very cute.
I don't know though, I don't think Tiny is so tiny.
No, look at those ears!
But what about Tiny's tiny chat I have?
I guess it's sort of tiny.
It's cute.
A tiny Santa hat on a big tiny.
Right?
How does tiny BAU BAU?
Tiny maybe.
You think it's tiny BAU BAU?
I don't think so.
Maybe tiny is excited for the holidays and that's what a big BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
I don't know, is that gonna get tiny lots of tweets?
I don't know, but that's just how you BAU BAU.
Maybe in between.
Maybe.
But you know Tiny is ready to see all his relatives and loved ones for Christmas.
Especially with that hat.
And you know, he wants to get lots of head pads and sheets so he's making sure to smell like a fresh dog and not like a wet dog.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And you know, how could you not want to give him some treats when he looks super cute at that height?
Right.
He doesn't need to have a super amazing cute BAU BAU.
It can be a big BAU BAU because he's very very cute.
Cute, cute.
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
That is a very big tree.
That is a very massive tree!
You know, it's almost as big as some of the trees you see here in the northwest passes.
But this one is much prettier, you know.
Look at the star on the top, too.
Why is it so big?
I wonder how many lights are on the tree.
Did somebody count it?
I think Moco-chan has too many to count.
Ruffians!
You should count it for Moco-chan, okay?
But Ruffians count how many times we say BAU BAU, so... That's true.
It's possible we could count how many likes there are on the tweet.
Yeah.
I think so.
Get to it, Ruffians!
Bye!
Thank you for sharing with us!
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day today, we have De-den!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
My question is, you know, different hololives have different chat vibes.
Example, the vibes in Biboo's chat is very different from Shiori's chat.
How would you describe the Ruffians' vibes?
I don't think you really thought of it that much, but... Comfy.
Cozy.
Silly.
Silly, very silly.
Silly!
Just us together with the Ruffians?
Yeah!
And rather well-behaved too.
Maybe sometimes.
Maybe today you're a bit rude though about the sauce and the nuggets.
Yeah, but rather well-behaved.
Yeah, we like it very much.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
That's too easy of an answer.
I don't know it's easy to answer.
It's easy to answer.
What can we do?
Ruffians don't make it hard for us.
No, no.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today!
Please remember, if you have any questions, ask us.
If you have any... Oh, this would make a good scoop!
Please put it in the FWMC scoop hashtag.
Your doggies are looking very cute for the holidays, and your walks are very festive, and, uh, well, your pero... Pero Sightings are... interesting.
Please don't forget, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, for our next theme, we have...
We have de-den!
School Days!
We're gonna be watching all of the School Days anime tonight from start to finish.
We're really excited!
It's an anime that's very special to us, that we like, and we like to watch it over Christmas.
As you might know, a lot of things have happened this past year.
And we can't really remember all that great anymore.
And I didn't watch it last year because I was doing something else.
I don't know what I was doing.
You wanted to do something else.
Maybe I was playing a game.
I don't know.
But, you know, that means it'll be like watching it for the first time again with you FUWAMOCO.
So, let's all get ready nice and cozy and prepare for some nice food!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
If we take a look at our schedule, there's not many days left before Christmas.
As you know, we have some big plans for Christmas Eve too.
Ruffians, are you gonna spend it with us?
Well, you know, this time we're trying something a bit different, so we really hope that you'll be there live with us.
But, you know, if your family is like, no, Ruffian, I want you for Christmas, then you go with your family, okay?
Okay.
That'd be pretty funny if they called you Ruffian.
But, we'd be really happy if you could join us because it is Christmas Eve with you, after all, so... BAU BAU!
Please look forward to it!
Wow, before we know it, today's FUWAMOCO Morning comes to a close!
We hope that you're gonna have a very happy holiday with us Ruffians.
It's almost the weekend.
Almost.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Marina!
BAU BAU!
Lettuce's!
Liang!
BAU BAU!
Yulius!
Takamachi.
BAU BAU!
Moomoo.
Magic.
BAU BAU!
Man in Tux.
K.A.R.I.S.O.L.A.
BAU BAU!
iDestiny.
Butter Ditto!
BAU BAU!
Kuroi!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!